[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Hello, and
welcome to the third episode
of our show about games.
My is Bruno Oliveira, and I work
on the Android Developer
Relations team.
TODD KERPELMAN: I am Todd
Kerpelman, and I am on the
Play Games Developer
Relations team.
And this is episode three of
"Game On!", our sort-of
every-couple-of-weekly
show about all
things games related.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And you're
probably wondering where
episodes one and two went.
And this is what we're
going to talk about.
TODD KERPELMAN: This brings
us right into
our news and updates.
And we'll start with--
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: --we actually
changed our name.
TODD KERPELMAN: We
have a name.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: We used to be
"The Google Play Game Show,"
and now we've changed to "Game
On!" Actually, that font looks
a little too modern
for my tastes.
Why don't we try something
more retro, like 8-bits?
Ah, that's much better.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's
a little better.
So you'll notice we added
the lens flares in
just for you gamers.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Absolutely.
TODD KERPELMAN: We know
you love lens flares.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And we have some
news on the iOS front.
Is that right?
TODD KERPELMAN: That's right.
On the iOS front, the big news
is, we just released an update
to the iOS SDK.
Version 1.1 is officially
available.
The biggest improvement that
you will probably notice is
that we have a new look for
the Achievement and the
Leaderboard widgets.
It's a little more of a modern
look, going with the aesthetic
of iOS moving forward.
So you'll probably notice
that right away.
We also have a number
of performance
improvements under the hood.
We've greatly improved
the caching
for leaderboard scores.
If, for instance, your user
switches back and forth
between daily, weekly, and
all-time leaderboard scores,
that will be much faster.
We do a better job
of batching and
submitting leaderboard scores.
If the user plays a bunch
offline, then comes back
online, all of their leaderboard
scores, all their
score submissions, will be
submitted in one nice little
batch instead of, say, multiple
score submissions.
So that'll be nice.
That'll be a lot
more efficient.
We have exposed that
call as well.
If you want to, for instance,
submit a couple of scores to a
couple of leaderboards all at
once, we now have a call
available for you to basically
batch all those up and make
those in one network call.
Which is really nice.
It saves on battery
and performance
and all of that stuff.
We've also made a number of
bug fixes and enhancements
and, in general, performance
improvements under the hood.
And so we encourage you
to check it out.
I do want to let you know about
a couple of gotchas.
First, there are two new
frameworks that are required
by this new library,
specifically,
CoreText.framework and
QuartzCore.framework.
So if you haven't included
those in your
project, you'll need to.
Also, with this new library,
you're going to need a
deployment target of
iOS 6.0 or greater.
Chances are you're probably
already doing
that with your game.
But if not, you are going to
need to change your deployment
target if you're using
this new library.
And so this library is available
from our site at
developers.googl
e.com/games/services.
And then look for the Downloads
link on the left.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And now, for
those of you who like tracking
bugs, and especially if you
like a public way to track
bugs, we have--
ta-da!--
a public bug tracker.
So if you've got a bug or a
feature to request, then you
can access that URL right
there, code.google.com/
p/play-games-platform.
TODD KERPELMAN: This is also
available from our Games page.
If you look on the left, of
there's now a link to, I
believe, Public Bug Tracker.
So if you notice any issues
with a game, or you have
requests, or anything
else, feel free
to submit them there.
I can't guarantee that we will
reply to every bug, but I can
guarantee we'll at least
look at them.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Absolutely.
And make sure to post only the
bugs that have to do with the
platform there.
If you find a bug in the
samples, then the
right place is GitHub.
And you go to GitHub,
and GitHub has
its own issues system.
TODD KERPELMAN: And if you find
a bug with a game, you're
still probably better off
contacting the game developer.
We can't debug every game.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: We didn't
make every game.
TODD KERPELMAN: No.
So with that out of the way,
let's move into this week's
topic, which is Cloud Save.
And so Cloud Save is
a great feature.
I think this service
is a little
under-utilized right now.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Absolutely.
It's missing on so many games.
I've lost count how many times
I've played a game and wished
it had Cloud Save.
Especially if you change
devices, and then you have to
lose all of your progress.
TODD KERPELMAN: I suppose Google
employees might have
more devices than your
typical consumer.
But even now, you're starting to
see consumers with a lot of
devices in the household.
Right?
Maybe they've got more
than one phone.
Maybe they've got a phone
and a tablet.
And they switch back and
forth between them.
And it would be great for your
users if they could keep their
progress between one device
and the next.
If they suddenly go from playing
your game on their
phone to opening up your game
on the tablet, and they
realize that they have to start
over again all the way
from level one, they're probably
just not going to
play your game on that device.
And maybe suddenly they decide
they've lost interest in it.
They're not playing
your game anymore.
They're not seeing ads.
They're not buying
in-game items.
They're not telling their
friends about it.
And it's bad for your users,
and it's bad for you, too.
So we really encourage you
to look into Cloud Save.
It's really just designed to
do one thing, and one thing
only, and that's sync your
users' progress from one
device to the next.
And so, with that big preamble
out of the way,
let's go into a demo.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Actually, before
we go into the demo,
it's important to notice that
Cloud Save is actually
cross-platform.
So you can even have, again, if
your game runs on Android
and iOS, you can save your state
on Android, and then
pick up the same state where
you left off on iOS, or
vice-versa.
So that's good for households
that have, like, one iPad, and
then one Android, and
one iPhone, and
then another Android.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
is very true.
I mean, that's starting to
become a common situation.
Households will have Android
phones and iPads, or they'll
have a Nexus 7 and an iPhone.
And being able to play your
game and continue progress
between those devices would
really be fantastic.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And if your game
also works on the web,
you can also share that
state on the web.
So that's pretty handy.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
is very true.
So with that in mind, we're
going to be demoing Samurai
vs. Zombies Defense 2-- this
is by Google Mobile--
partly because it's a pretty
good example of Cloud Save.
And also because--
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And also
because it has
samurais and zombies.
TODD KERPELMAN: And zombies.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Nothing at
all wrong with that.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
It's a pretty fun game.
So with that, this is the game
right now running on--
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So this
is a Galaxy Nexus.
TODD KERPELMAN: My Galaxy
Nexus phone.
And I would love to show you
more of the game, but we're
limited in time.
So I'm just going to do
something real quick here.
I'm going to start
the game up.
And the game starts me
in a storefront.
And so I think--
oop.
Do I want to download
this game?
Eh, not right now.
But thanks for asking.
All right.
So you'll notice I have
about 920 of these
little silver coins.
I'm going to use them to
upgrade this hero here,
Kunoichi, from level
one to level two.
So, yes, let's upgrade
her health.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: All right.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
She's been upgraded.
Now I'm going to go back
to the main menu.
And the game does save to
the Cloud automatically.
However, because we're in a demo
situation, I'm going to
manually force a save.
So it's going to say, OK, I'm
going to save to the Cloud
next chance I have.
And hopefully, it's doing
that right now.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: All right.
Now let's switch to our tablet
and see if that worked.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right so
I'm on the Nexus 10 now.
And I'm just going to force a
Cloud Load here by going into
the Cloud Load menu.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Notice that
normally this would happen
automatically.
We're just forcing it so that
we can actually do this in a
demo time frame instead
of sitting around
waiting for it to upload.
But normally the user would
not have to do this.
So now we're loading
the game again.
So remember that Todd upgraded
the character
on the Galaxy Nexus.
So what we should see when the
game loads is that the
character is going
to be upgraded.
So we should see a higher-level
character than we
had before.
TODD KERPELMAN: Should
see that.
Fingers crossed.
Let's see here.
I'm going to start.
And look at that!
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And
there we go.
So it's the same level,
level three.
You were level three
before, right?
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, yeah.
Or, I guess, level two.
That option is to upgrade
to level three.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Oh, yeah.
That's true.
TODD KERPELMAN: Point being,
my progress is carried over
from one device to the next.
And now I can keep playing on
the Nexus 10, which actually
has a much better framerate.
So this is a better platform
to play on anyway.
So I'm just going to take this
with me after the show.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Perfect.
TODD KERPELMAN: So there we go.
All right.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So, conflict
management.
So Cloud Save is pretty
convenient.
It can save and it can load.
But then imagine what happens
if two devices try to save
conflicting states at the
same time to the Cloud?
So I'm playing here on my
tablet, and then I upgrade my
character to level two.
And then on my phone, I upgrade
the same character to
level four without syncing
up the changes.
What's going to happen
is what's called
a Cloud Save conflict.
So you need to think about those
Cloud Save conflicts and
then handle them in a way that
makes sense for your app.
So if you want to take a look,
that link over there is a link
to a white paper that we wrote
that talks about many
strategies to handle Cloud Save
conflicts, and how to
make that in a way that makes
sense, and that--
and this is especially
important-- in a way that
doesn't lose any progress
for the user.
TODD KERPELMAN: Right.
So it's a pretty in-depth
bit of reading.
My takeaway, if you just want
some general advice, is when
you're trying to resolve to
Cloud Saves, resolve these two
states in isolation.
Don't assume, based on the local
user's game state or
anything, you know more
than what you get from
the Cloud Save data.
Just because it gets a little
tricky, but due to, sometimes,
the way that we give you these
two states to resolve, they
might not be, actually, in the
time frame you expect.
So, long story short, try and
resolve these two states as if
this is the only
date you have.
And just try and forget about
the rest of the world when
you're doing that.
And I suppose there's a
couple ways you can
look at this problem.
One way is, if you want to be
clever, do it Bruno's way,
which would be--
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: You can look at
the two states and see if
there's a clever way in which
you can merge them together,
instead of just picking
one or the other.
Sometimes it might just
make sense to
pick one or the other.
But sometimes, if you notice
that they have discrepancies,
it might make sense to merge
them intelligently together.
So this is what, for instance,
our sample, Collect All The
Stars, does.
Which is, for instance, if you
unlock a few levels on one
device, and then unlock a
different set of levels on a
different device, then what it
does, is it actually combines
those two saves into one.
It doesn't choose one.
It doesn't choose the other.
But it actually combines them
into a single save that has
all of those levels unlocked.
TODD KERPELMAN: And if you think
about a lot of games--
Cut The Rope, Angry Birds,
Where's My Water, Where's My
Mickey, which is awesome--
if you think about the way those
games work, in general,
you have stars on every level,
and you have high scores on
each level.
And that can be pretty safely
unioned between two
conflicting sets of data.
If you have two stars on level
1.4 on this device, and three
stars on level 1.4 on this other
device, that's something
you can very easily merge just
by saying, let's take the
greater number of stars.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Stars may be an
easy case, but be careful
about stuff like virtual
currency, because it can get
into hard-to-predict problems.
So more details about that
in the white paper.
TODD KERPELMAN: And then, of
course, if you don't want to
be clever, just ask the user.
Say, hey, you know what,
we found these two
sets of Cloud data.
This one looks like it was
saved on July 30 on this
device, and this one looks like
it was saved on August 1
at this time on this device.
You're at level four with a
thief on this one, and you're
at level five with a paladin
on this device.
Which one do you really want?
Ask the user.
Bring up the dialogue.
Chances are the user will know
which one they want.
And go with what they pick.
So if you want more information,
check the Docs.
You probably knew we were
going to say that,
but there's the link.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Becuase we
say that on every show.
TODD KERPELMAN: We kind of do.
But go to the Docs.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: We really
love our Docs.
TODD KERPELMAN: We spend
a lot of time on them.
You should read them.
We have a link to Cloud Save
there on general concepts.
You can read up more about it.
Read Bruno's white paper.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And then, of
course, if you want some real
excitement, you can try our
sample app, which is Collect
All The Stars.
TODD KERPELMAN: And we have
versions for Collect All The
Stars on Android,
iOS, and web.
So you can see what it looks
like saving one state on one
device and another state on
another completely different
device, and watching your
progress carry over.
It's pretty magical.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And it's a
very challenging game.
TODD KERPELMAN: It is.
So yeah.
That too.
So I think that pretty much
wraps it up for episode three
of "Game On!" We'll be back
in a couple weeks
with episode four.
We'll probably keep
the same title.
So just start searching
for it.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: All right.
So thanks everybody, and
see you next time.
TODD KERPELMAN: Thanks,
video audience.